foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is SCP
2464.
object class
ketter
special containment procedures
restricted access to
scp-2464-1 is to be maintained via five
checkpoint stations designated area 2464
1-5 spaced roughly five kilometers apart
from each other throughout the primary
access tunnel access into area
24645 is only to be granted to
individuals with level 4 clearance or
the members of authorized exploration or
maintenance teams individuals who gain
access past area 2464 1 are to be
contained brought to site 81 for
examination and subsequently
administered class D amnestics or
terminated
these stone slabs separating
scp-2464-1 from area
24645 is to be kept in place at all
times except in the event of scheduled
exploration or to provide maintenance to
oscp 2464-4 should
scp-2464-2 breach containment preset
charges along the main access tunnel of
site 2464 are to be detonated and the
tunnel is to be collapsed if
scp-2464-2 is able to escape the
collapsed tunnel the on-site nuclear
device is to be detonated below the
current location of provisional site 81
2464.
maintenance of
scp-2464-4 is the primary concern in
regards to continued containment of
scp-2464.2 research into the design and
function of
scp-2464-4 is ongoing and should be
considered the top priority under no
circumstances even during maintenance of
scp-2464-4 should
scp-2464-2 and
scp-2464-3 be disturbed in any way
description
scp-2464-1 is a temporal and spatial
anomaly existing within the Morris
Limestone mine designated provisional
site 81 2464 located near the town of
Indiana
scp-2464-1 is only accessible through
the removal of a large stone slab that
covers its only entrance and other
methods of attempting to access
scp-2464-1 have proven unsuccessful
cutting into the only space where
scp-2464-1 should be located reveals
only solid limestone
the interior of
scp-2464-1 usually appears to be a large
open field of Rolling Hills that extends
indefinitely in all directions situated
roughly 50 meters in front of the
entrance to
scp-2464-1 is a 1960s American Farmhouse
in a state of advanced disrepair
analysis of plant matter with an
scp-2464-1 has revealed no unknown or
foreign biological substances the sun
within
scp-2464-1 is perpetually situated at
dusk two anomalous entities and one
anomalous machine are contained within
the Farmhouse all are located in the
second floor master bedroom which
contains only a bed
scp-24642 3 and 4.
scp-2464-2 is a human female aged
approximately 12 years
scp-2464-2 is roughly 1.4 meters in
height with brown hair that appears to
have not been cut for several years eye
color cannot be currently determined
scp-24642 is situated on the bed within
the second floor master bedroom
scp-24642 is perpetually open-mouthed
but otherwise unmoving and unresponsive
likely due to the effects of scp-2464 3
and 4.
scp-2464-2 is held to the bed by
shackles located on its wrists and
ankles although all are severely rusted
for more information on
scp-2464.2 please see addendum 2464 2X
scp-2464-3 is the identical twin sister
of
scp-2464.2
scp-2464-3 is suspended on the ceiling
above
scp-2464.2 by a series of iron clasps
around the knees ankles elbows wrists
torso and neck
scp-2464-3 is similarly unresponsive
likely due to the effects of
scp-2464-4
scp-24643 is extremely emaciated and
constantly secretes a viscous black
liquid through its mouth which falls
into the open mouth of
scp-2464.2 the source of this liquid is
currently unknown
scp-2464-4 is a machine believed to be
designed and constructed by the late Dr
Michael Banning a foundation researcher
from 1934 to 1975. it is situated within
the second floor master bedroom against
the north facing wall
scp-2464-4 consists of a main Hub and a
number of copper tubes which run up the
wall and towards
scp-2464-3 these tubes all enter
scp-2464-3 via copper access ports on
its right side just below the armpit
additionally a number of biological
components have been discovered at
various locations throughout the
apparatus although their purpose is
currently unknown the entirety of
scp-2464-4 is in a state of disrepair
and is the subject of an ongoing attempt
to fully restore the entire mechanism
the apparent purpose of
scp-2464-4 is to extend the lifespan of
scp-24643 by means of preventing
scp-2464-3 from aging while this process
appears to have been thus far effective
and apparent side effect is the
degeneration of these cell tissues of
scp-2464-3 resulting in a number of
cancers appearing throughout the body
while the rate of expansion of these
cancers has been kept to a minimum by
scp-2464-4 due to the machine's state of
repair current models predict
scp-2464-4 will be unable to sustain its
current processes for longer than an
additional 10 years without repair which
will likely result in the expiration of
scp-2464-3
discovery
scp-2464 was initially discovered during
routine Limestone cutting by Morris
Limestone Personnel who reported that
they had broken through the Limestone
shelf into a clearing on the other side
after the nature of the
scp-2464-1 was assessed Foundation
agents took control of the mine and set
up provisional site 2464. after a
thorough examination of The Farmhouse
within
scp-2464-1 it became clear that The
Farmhouse was the one owned by Dr
Banning until it burned down in 1975.
upon entering the second floor master
bedroom Foundation Personnel found
scp-2464-4 in a state of considerable
disrepair it was noted within the
original Discovery report that although
scp-2464-4 was experiencing several
catastrophic malfunctions of critical
components of its engineering it did not
give any indication that it was not
performing its job as design throughout
attempts to repair
scp-2464-4 even when other considerable
failures have occurred
scp-2464-4 has shown little sign of
stopping at all
addendum 2464 2X
information restricted to level 4
Personnel or above
input credentials
credentials accepted
it is currently believed that
scp-24642 is a class 4 reality bending
entity and that the entirety of
scp-2464-1 outside of the existence of
scp-2464 3 and 4 is a result of that
nature
although
scp-2464-2 has not shown any evidence of
active reality bending during its time
within Foundation containment the
presence of the spatial anomaly coupled
with the information gathered from Dr
banning's personal files has led to the
conclusion that the function of
scp-2464-3 was a means by which to hold
scp-2464-2 in an indefinite stasis
within which it would be unable to
utilize its anomalous characteristics
despite this it seems as if
scp-2464-2 is capable of bending reality
subconsciously likely resulting in the
creation of scp-2464-1
it is also currently believed that where
scp-2464-4 to malfunction and
scp-24643 to expire as a result
scp-2464-2 would be released from its
current stasis given the information
gathered from Dr banning's logs about
the severely deteriorated mental state
of his daughter it is well within the
realm of possibility that this event
could trigger an RK class reality
restructuring scenario by means of
scp-2464 twos out of control reality
disruptions
because of these factors and has been
proposed to the containment committee
that
scp-2464 be upgraded from Euclid to
ketter to express the enormity of
importance in maintaining scp-2464-4
incident report
during routine maintenance of
scp-2464-4 on 7 15 2013 the maintenance
team leader reported hearing sounds
coming from the second floor master
bedroom before his team had reached it
upon entering the room the team leader
reported that
scp-24643 had its eyes open a trait that
had not been observed during containment
the order was given to perform the
maintenance on
scp-2464-4 as instructed and continued
to monitor scp-2464-3
the scheduled maintenance went without
further complication the team leader
reported that
scp-2464-3 would follow members of his
team with its eyes but showed no other
movement of any kind maintenance team
departed from The Farmhouse with no
complications and
scp-24643 has not displayed this type of
activity since
overseer proposal response
scp-2464 upgrade from Euclid to ketter
approved
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you're all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Indy versus the world
big sip
tomothy
zargaron
the Morrigan
fire of prime
Spencer arduin
rubbish bin 69.
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J telp
vinyl
zazapan
Lemke
Dr Briggs
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
London B Johnson
oh crop guy
and James Saba
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you